Sam welcome back to the show this was a
very tense game but I have to say you
got a great position out of the opening
and you were playing really really good
uh moves when did you feel like you lost
control and allowed your opponent back
into the
game after Bishop C6 check I thought the
game would just win itself and then he
blitzed out king E3 at which point I
realized I cannot just go Knight D5
Knight C3 like I wanted Bishop to remind
us around which time was this right here
uh I gave Bishop C6 check I can't see
the boorder okay maybe you have you have
it on yours 42 or 43 yeah now I see yeah
so after yeah Bishop C6 check I thought
was a very bad move and after King E3
I'm already I was already really
struggling to find a plan mhm like I
cannot just go Knight D5 Knight C3 I
don't think because he'll go A4 and I
couldn't figure out how I'm actually
going to do anything and is King is
coming to become annoying and
it's it was very difficult to come up
with a plan here maybe I should have I
think at that point it was Knight
D7 um instead of so the move was Bishop
C6 king3 the best move was Knight D7 I
saw this but after King D4 what's my
next
move or Bishop E4 even I was not sure
about a bishop E4 I should just take a
knight F6 yeah this was probably a
better way and King F6 now or something
yeah King F6 maybe just Bishop B5 as
well
yeah okay but this is not was struggling
to find a B5 um I think was yeah and
then yeah I guess there's never Bishop
E4 because it's always taken Knight F6
yeah so I just undo the stupid Bishop C6
from before yeah so Bishop I thought
Bishop E8 was winning but I had missed
an important detail and what was the
detail I think already it's just a draw
so I saw this Knight C5 and I thought I
just missed that he's going Knight A6 I
thought he's going and then Knight B8 I
thought he was going Knight B7 instead
of Knight A6 that's what I had
calculated at least mhm uh Knight B7
here and then my point was after Knight
takes
H5 uh whichever Knight he takes on A5
with say Knight B takes A5 King D7 his
Knights are now incredibly stupid and
permanently stupid uh and they cannot be
fixed and I thought that I will win the
game with the H Pawn
routinely uh so this is what I had in
mind when I played Bishop B8 or at least
that's what I calculated but I missed
that after King E7 Knight a six I just
missed Knight C5 and Knight B8 I missed
and after Knight B8 I think White's
Making a draw
easily yeah so yeah because I was just
one time basically this position here
after Knight takes A5 go back to
it um yeah after Knight takes A5 I I
believe King D7 is the winning move
essentially and by this Knight B8 Knight
a knight A6 B8 business my king ended up
on the wrong Square uh is a good way of
explaining it and that's one thing that
we were discussing as you were getting
miked up it's all these very difficult
decisions uh under tremendous tension
and pressure how do you deal with
that I don't know I've been doing it for
my whole adult life I'm just I'm just
used to it I mean trust me you screw up
enough uh as much as I have in life you
you're used to making mistakes and you
don't worry about making more absolutely
you just uh pull yourself back up and
keep
moving yeah yes sir uh no I just uh
we've been enjoying the tournament uh we
had that one round Sam it was
immediately after the free day where we
had five decisive games out of the six
in the open section and maybe it's one
of those uh periods where there's a lull
six draws yesterday and maybe we're
going to see I don't know six draws uh
today how do you explain that how do you
get all theis of
games been the main contributor because
I should have drawn the game with
Dominguez at the end uh and I also
should have won this game so I was the
contributor to the 6os uh for sure um
but yeah I mean sometimes it's just luck
of the draw I mean for me I try to play
fighting trust every single game I mean
I I'm very risk-loving player these days
uh so you know I but every now and then
games are just drawn I mean yesterday
like Darius completely shut me down and
I didn't have a chance at all ever and I
was just worse at some point so you know
I'm I'm trying to fight every game I
think today I showed I was like ready to
fight with black like for example after
he played E4 in the opening like I
believe E5 is just a draw it's like D5
Knight B6 Bishop B3 Bishop G4 trade
everything big draw and I decided to
keep the game going even with the black
pieces when on paper a draw with black
yeah kir E5 as far as I know is just
supposed to be a draw making like three
more moves yeah um but I decided to keep
the fight going even with the black
pieces when on paper draw with black
against San is fine uh so I'm just
trying to play combative Fighting Chess
every round um but chess is just such a
drawish game in its nature that
sometimes that's what you're going to
get and you got your chances and this is
exactly what we love to see here at the
US Championship very combative chess
thank you uh for displaying that Sam
we'll see you tomorrow yeah sure
absolutely and